non
c'est une oeuvre historique un film de
fiction qui a pris 12 ans a tourné avec
les mêmes acteurs du début à la fin
un tour de force
elle en avait 6 ans au début du tournage
18 à la toute fin à tous les ans ou
presque
l'équipe repartait en tournage pour
raconter l'histoire d'une famille
éclatée dont les parents sont joués par
michel roth et patchwork
le film a été présenté à berlin où il a
obtenu le prix de la meilleure
réalisation
remis in dans jeunesse ou bollywood en
anglais le temps s'avère une force
positive l'épanouissement des enfants
est d'autant plus émouvant qu'il
s'inscrit dans leurs traits
qu'attend les acteurs n'ont rien vu du
tournage avant le montage final
troc tu mets un soulagement pour lui la
fille du réalisateur ben woods n'est pas
un drame typique
il capte les moments du quotidien tout
en documentant l'évolution des
technologies et les changements dans la
culture populaire
c'est réussi à tout point de vue
surtout la fluidité des transitions
d'une année à l'autre
bien qu'il soit encore tous les rumeurs
de nomination aux oscars circulent déjà
robot est rude c'est un film
révolutionnaire une expérience unique
autant pour les acteurs que les
cinéphiles ici tanya lapointe radio
canada montréal